i don't know if joe douglas
is the colonel jessup here it's
definitely not adam gates because he's
not long for this world michael holly
i i just refuse to believe that
somewhere there isn't
a phony transfer order or a law
book a log book that's been doctored i
greg williams is a lot of things michael
greg williams is a lot of things
egotistical
selfish know it all go down the list
he's not stupid he's not stupid
well he he's not an idiot i have a
i so if i let me just allow me off the
top right now
off the top let me go all the way
conspiracy brother oh wait conspiracy
brother
they had to be covered in their tracks
today in firing greg williams
the jets had to be covering their tracks
for ordering the code red aka
an all out blitz with the spy
and cover zero up four
with the raiders having the ball at the
46 and 13 seconds left and no timeouts
there's no other explanation for it
this has got to be an organizational
orchestrated decision to take that game
because no coach in his right
mind calls a play
like that in that situation
because because i immediately went
conspiracy michael then when he got
fired i'm like well maybe not
but i'm sorry he's not that stupid
nobody is
mike far be it for me to call her
brother stupid okay i'm just
that that's just not what i'm trying to
do right right that was a stupid
decision
on a monday but i'll tell you this he
was stupid yesterday
and he it wasn't just stupid yesterday
he was stupid a few games ago too i've
seen this the jets have only been in
like a handful of
uh close games take away a couple of my
fingers and i can still count all the
close games they've been in this year
so it hasn't been a lot of competitive
situations for the jets
but in the last competitive situation i
saw the jets in
one of one of the last few it was
against the patriots
the score was 27 to 27.
the game was going to overtime mike the
game was going overtime
not watch the game with a couple of
ex-football players and they're sitting
there this is like what week seven
week eight yeah they're sitting there
saying what is this defensive greg
williams has his team in because you're
trying to prevent the field goal and you
know what happened
you know the jets did win since they're
winless nick folk
former jet came out kicked the 50-yard
field goal to win the game
the reason he was able to do that is
because the defense greg williams had
them in
so yes he's not a stupid person he was
stupid yesterday but i'm going to reject
your entire premise
okay because you they're not
jets aren't tanking they're not tanking
they're not tanking
we're acting like and i feel like we say
this so much
that it becomes true we're acting like
we haven't seen windless teams in the
nfl
recently with no prize at the end of the
rainbow
i mean i i saw the jets i mean excuse me
that's all the lions go oh 116. i saw
the browns go
lebron's doing it absolutely that's the
last one
10 to 12 years two teams two openings
that wasn't for lack of trying
that wasn't for lack of trouble right
the difference because they're trying
i think they're trying because this this
is why that's why
uh tanking doesn't tanking doesn't help
you for a couple of reasons
yeah i'm gonna get to the to the big one
last
it doesn't help you because most people
involved in the tank
unless they're extremely sacrificial
human beings
like i just the more you make it better
yep this is gonna make it better for
everybody else
yes because if you're tanking and you go
oh and 16
guess who's not going to be around to
reap the benefits you
got and if you're tanking you're greg
williams hey
why are you putting that on tape you got
you got another job to go to if you're
adam
gates you got to get another job don't
you no
okay do it all right but can i tell you
the other reason you wouldn't tank yeah
you know please please
this is good because it's not the nba
this is not the nba it's the nfl
and there is no evidence there is none
where you just bring in a guy and all of
a sudden your franchise
is just healed ooh let me just reach out
let me let me let me td jakes you
let me lay hands on you and you're all
fixed that's not happening touch the hem
of this garment right no i got you
i got you right i got you so okay what
you got counter
easy thank you your honor cross-examine
no listen
oh you just first of all in pointing out
the patriots
debacle what you identified as a pattern
that's what you identified so there's a
pattern of behavior here
when it comes to new and creative ways
to lose games that you seemingly have in
hand okay
then you just hit it mike's a record
taking is almost
that simple i'm gonna let you continue
what's what's the record just remind me
of the record again
there's all in 12 now right oh okay that
talk about the pattern okay all right
okay
go ahead well no but i'm talking about a
pattern of quest like what are they
doing like because even after i remember
after that patriots game
we were like yo congratulations way to
get the win
because you came dangerously close to
winning that game
and costing yourself draft position as
it relates to trevor lawrence okay
we'll get to him in a second yeah but
then the second part brother
look you hit it right on the head like
tanking is hard because to get a
coordinated
uh organized conspiracy especially with
players involved
players who have the eye in the sky that
doesn't lie
and have their futures and their their
employment
on the line they're not going to be in
on it
unless you put them in a position
where you have no choice and the only
way
to get 11 dudes in on the tank
is to send seven of them after derek
carr
one of them as a spy leaves zero
coverage
and have an undrafted rookie quarterback
named lamar jackson not that lamar
jackson because i'm like well maybe he
thought he had baltimore lamar jackson
no let's put that lamar jackson
undrafted rookie out of nebraska
on the second fastest player in the nfl
after tyrek hill
one on one okay double move or not damn
a double move what you're supposed to do
one-on-one with no safety help that's
the only way you get the players
to participate in said tank by taking
the decision out of your hands
michael i'm sorry i don't like
conspiracies i don't like
you not just i'm the most logical
practical person that you can think of
michael i the reason i have no choice
but to believe it
is because there have been 252 past
plays
meeting the following criteria in the
last 15 seasons
final 15 seconds down four to eight
points
40 plus yards to the end zone the jets
were the first defense
to send six or more pass rushers in that
situation
in the last 15 years and you know why
it's just the last 15 years
because that's as far back as espn stats
and information goes with such data
i guarantee you it's in the history of
the nfl
nobody has ever in the in the in the
history of life
nfl football college football flag
football
touch football life paper football
for any other football nobody has ever
set a blitz
in that situation unless you're trying
to lose
so okay the way to cover your tracks is
to fire the coach but i guarantee you
joe douglas on the way out said thank
you for your service
because whether or not you believe that
one player could turn the franchise
around
clearly the jets do and by the way
before i pass this back to you michael
remember i had this we had this
conversation earlier in the year about
me making the argument
that there was something to be said for
keeping sam darnold building a better
team around him
and drafting penny sewell out of oregon
with the first pick
sorry about that yeah that was almost as
dumb as greg williams called last night
because you don't tank for a tackle
and i'll be damned that that wasn't
tanking at its finest last night there's
no other way to explain it because no
defensive coordinator would ever call
that under any other circumstances
unless you're trying to maintain your
position in the draft there's no other
way to let me exaggerate it's ridiculous
that sounds
it's not more ridiculous than the call
itself let me exaggerate to make a point
can i can i can i do that all right i'll
do it all the time
if uh that's fine that's right let's say
let's say um uh the
let me think of a good team let's say a
good team
a good team right now uh didn't want to
uh
make the playoffs let's just go like
your indianapolis colts
indianapolis colts you don't want to
make the playoffs
you're eight and four and you're afraid
that you might sneak in i don't know why
you don't want to make you just don't
want to make it
covet i don't know if you hire me
as your head coach you're not
necessarily tanking
you're not doing anything like a a
sinister
you're just hiring somebody who can't do
the job well
and then you're gonna get what you
signed up for
well that's that's why they're not
tanking so that's the that's the out of
the face in this analogy
but not only adam gasol not just adam
gates it's his whole staff
and that's why no but greg williams is
better than that
because a madden player knows better
than to call that defense in that
situation
he doesn't come on mike he doesn't know
it doesn't make anybody else you you set
it off the top
i'm gonna tell you why he doesn't know
better you said he's got an ego
and people with big egos and i don't
know how outsized his ego is but i've
heard that many times about him
yeah yeah so if you're one of those
there's a joke about this
that i don't remember but yeah exactly
yeah
so people people with big egos
people who are ruled by agendas they
wind up
doing things that make that take their
smarts
and just wipe them out like smart people
with big
egos look stupid um
really uh people with agendas who are
smart
they look stupid because they can't get
past
that that block it's like it really i'm
a psychoanalyst
so well i will see if he's not i wasn't
yeah no i was just gonna say i will say
i will say
yes the only other thing and again
is as far fetched as everything i'm
saying and i'm not the only person that
buys it as hell yeah
jets fans thanking him on the way out on
twitter
as far-fetched as the idea of him being
part of a conspiracy to tank especially
after he got fired as far-fetched as it
is
i believe it over this but the other
th what i'm about to say but the only
other thing i could have thought of
today that i was like yo well maybe
could he have been outsmarting himself
and thinking okay if i send an all-out
blitz
then i forced derek carr to get rid of
it
quickly yeah and then it's
you know he can't get the ball to the
end zone maybe
and and and the reason why it didn't
work is because the undrafted rookie
cornerback
bent on the double move but even then
here's why that doesn't fly michael
because if you leave three people back
in coverage
and he gets rid of the ball quickly
especially
to a henry ruggs iii he might score
anyway like there was no there is
michael i'm sorry absent absent logic
we reach for conspiracies
and i'm and i and there's you're up for
with no timeouts
nobody's that selfish ego maniacal
narcissistic to think
that i gotta end this game on a sack as
opposed or this is the best way to do
this there's a reason why nobody's ever
played this coverage at least in the
last 15 years
is because it's dumb you don't need
to pressure the quarterback in that
situation you put everybody back
michael come on like what else could it
be nobody so
there's nobody i'm sorry michael i got a
there's got to be something afoot
and to win a jets figure let's fire the
coordinator who won't be here the rest
of the year anyway
let's just fire him so people will think
this wasn't intentional so the league
won't think we're doing some
okay mike all right well you know what i
got another conspiracy for you i got
another one for you all right how about
this all right how about this
okay good this is a tim donaghy type
thing
there's some gambling involved okay
you're a gambling man there's some
gambling involved how about that yeah
would you buy that would you cuz it's
not football
this was not the best football decision
so okay if it's not tanking
somebody has some money on the line and
it needs to be a deeper investigation
and i'm saying that tongue-in-cheek
but i'm telling you there is no logical
football
reason to ever call a defense like that
unless there's something else going on i
can't see it
okay i hate to do this i hate to
hate to say what i'm about to say
because mike
some of my best friends are jets fans
um but i hate to do this
if they've been tanking they've been
tanking since 1969
the last time they won the super bowl
this is
one of the worst organizations but this
is the history of football
this is why we don't know they don't
often end up with the number one
pick oh you made me they don't normally
get the number one pick they normally
are in that like
five and 11 range you may this is the
first time to get a generational guy
since peyton manning
when he didn't come out remember hey my
mike
they've had they've had generational
players they've had generational coaches
this is the only franchise in nfl
history
who's hired bill belichick twice yet
he's never coached
a game he's a two-time head coach of the
new york jets without coaching the game
they have bill parcells
they had they had bill belichick they
had one of the best corners
i've ever seen in darrell rivas they
traded him
they watched him win a super bowl with
the patriots
then they came back and got them too
late paid them and watched them get old
watch them get old on their watch i mean
they i feel you
they have done so many stupid things
in the history of their i hate to do
this jets fans i love you all but look
they have done so many stupid things in
the history of the organization
fireman ed you know the j-e-t-s gesture
he retired on him he quit
fired environment and quit their mastery
quit
i get it i get it i'm strictly talking
about x's and o's
and i'm saying to you mike i don't
i don't want to believe i don't want to
believe
they can't help that this is a
conspiracy that this is an orchestrated
effort to
intentionally throw a game i don't want
to believe it
but something unbelievable happened
yesterday i just don't know what else to
believe
unless there's unless there's an
explanation out there that i'm missing
that's unbelievable
i'm like you told me can you tell me
that you don't like horror movies you
told me that right yeah my nerves too
bad
yeah nerves too bad okay so the jets
if you're in the movies you're watching
the jet you're like no
no no no don't do that but it's like
that's on loop
that like if you you're in that movie
theater and you're a jets fan
you've been in that movie theater for 50
years
like like this is yeah you know i'm not
lying and jess fans know i'm not lying
i hate to do this to you i i really do
i'm sorry i'm apologizing in advance
you know what they brag about so since
the merger
1970 you know just a few few years ago
1970
since the merger you know what a jets
fan
can brag about that time they went to
two straight
conference championship games and lost
oh oh
remember that time we had parcells as
the head coach
oh i'm telling you i know a lot of you
as a coordinator
and we went to the conference
championship game and we went up
michael 10 nothing on john elway and
lost
like you were but you're not going to
tell me this is you're not going to tell
me but
let me i'm a pivot because we're coming
up against the break and i need you i
need to i need to get your opinion on
something before we come up against the
break
you're not going to tell me that the
best outcome
was not achieved yesterday because that
was
what was best for the team was for them
to lose
and that's the bottom line whether it's
intentional or not
they're better off on 12 than they would
be at one in 11.
and i'll get to justin fields versus
trevor lawrence hopefully later in the
show
but the best thing for the franchise
was for them to lose that game and greg
williams said what you want about him
he did his job deep down in places we
don't want to talk about at parties
he did his job that having been said
michael
there was a report i don't know if you
won't call a report but uh boomer siason
on wfan suggested today
that yes bill coward that suggested he
said
that bill cower told him uh-oh that the
jets
job is the best job out there
and my antennas went up not just because
boomerang siason
works with bill cower on cbs
but as long as they've been knowing each
other as close as they are
boomer assassin ain't going on radio and
suggesting that bill cower
might be interested in the jets job
without bill cower's either blessing
or instruction for that matter so
i think there's something to this and
that's an easy call for the new york
jets
no it's really interesting uh bill cower
is a guy
that i i know uh pretty well i have a
great amount of respect for him
uh as a man as a man more than a coach
mike
like that's my guy so um
it's interesting to me because when he
left the scoop when he left pittsburgh
what's that yeah i said give me the
scoop with them
oh girls give me this okay i don't claim
to have the scoop
but i'm just telling how much how much
respect i have for the man
and i think when he left when he left
pittsburgh i believe it was after the 06
season so he left he left pittsburgh
then
uh he's got three daughters so two of
his daughters were in college
one of his daughters was in high school
he was just at a different place in his
life
you know he had been coaching for all
those years in pittsburgh
now you think about it uh he's been out
of coaching
for 14 years and now now his kids are
grown
um yeah boomer said his wife likes
new york yeah he said he said his wife's
like i don't know actually i think his
wife's a jets fan not only they love new
york but his wife's a jets fan
it's not another size yeah but i don't
know what he's gonna do but this is what
i do know
and you will disagree with you will push
back on this all day long but i believe
it i know that i know that i know that i
know you don't know my life
you don't know i know you i know you
what what about girls okay go ahead they
don't have to tank
for the the answer the the answer to
fixing the jets
is closer than trevor trevor lawrence
all the way
in south carolina the answer is not in
south carolina their answer might be in
new york with bill
cower bill cower does more for the jets
without trevor lawrence than trevor
lawrence does for the jets without bill
cower if that makes any sense
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m
eastern time on peacock appreciate you